hey guys my name is Jess it is the 7th
of April today and you are watching
games but need two divisions 1.1 update
is introducing the game's first
incursion mission which is basically a
raid and apparently it's so hard the
game's lead designer hasn't been able to
beat it the Falcon lost incursion has no
checkpoints which means teams will have
to start over if all members are killed
in a community podcast to lead designer
Matthias Carlson revealed that these
missions will come at a default hard
setting which is supposedly the
equivalent of the hardest difficulty
challenging on current mission so if you
opt to do the incursion mission on
challenging that will be harder still
Carson said I have not beaten it on
challenge mode it needs to have been
beaten once by one team the studio for
it to be published just so we know it
can be done in other division use the
April update will also introduce a new
play reporting system which could result
in permanent bands for offending players
who are caught cheating twice the PC
version of the game is currently home to
players using ball hacks among other
things telltale has revealed they will
be bringing PC survival horror game 7
days to die to xbox one and ps4 The
Walking Dead publisher in collaboration
with the original developer the fun
pimps will be adding new multiplayer
modes to the game as well as skins based
on their walking dead series the first
multiplayer mode adds the local split
screen and telltale have said more modes
features and DLC will be on their way at
a later date 7 days to die calls for the
player to craft looped mine and try not
to get eaten by zombies wherever
possible the game will be out on
consoles in June for thirty bucks and if
you decide to pre-order telltale will
give you five exclusive character skins
including The Walking Dead's Lee Everett
hasn't shown user reviews for the steam
early access version currently sit at
very positive finally fallout 4 have
nabbed itself another game of year award
this time it's a BAFTA from the British
Academy games
what following its Game of the Year win
at the dice awards back in February and
it's go to win on my personal games of
the year list back in December Vlad for
now has another prestigious win to add
to the collection flat for beat out
games like metal gear solid 5 The
Witcher 3 rocket League and life is
strange elsewhere during the ceremony
doom and quake designer John Carmack was
awarded the fellowship award for being a
pioneer of 3d graphics you can check out
the full list of winners which include
re in the blind forest everybody's gone
to the rapture her story and blood-borne
in our article on game SWAT let me know
down in that comment section if you're
happy about fallout 4 winning another
one and we should head to gamespot well
we've got stories on Gears of War for
and Mass Effect Andromeda that is
everything I have for you today but do
pop by same time tomorrow for the
biggest stories of the entire week I
will see you then